states rights states rights are a
beautiful thing according to the
constitutional right I love this picture
of a GTI with a huge Reese's coffee mug
states rights might be the path to
reinstating net neutrality by law the
California State Senate has approved a
bill that would impose net neutrality
restrictions on Internet service
providers that want to operate in the
state of California and of course the
FCC under the leadership of Trump
appointee a GPI recently destroyed the
Obama era net neutrality regulations we
covered it extensively the whole way
this is not a simple victory in
California though because when the FCC
repealed net neutrality regulations they
anticipated that states might try to
impose their own and the FCC actually
included a provision which says state
and local governments can't enforce
rules at the local level but many states
are actually moving forward and trying
to do it anyway the FCC is being sued by
21 states and Washington DC to try to at
least reverse the preemption of local
net neutrality laws and in California SB
460 has passed the Senate this is a bill
which says that if you're an internet
service provider and you want to do
business in California you can't
participate in the blocking of any
lawful content applications services or
non non-harmful devices you're not
allowed to do any throttling meaning the
slowing down of access to certain
websites or applications you wouldn't be
allowed to establish paid prioritization
or preferential treatment to some
internet traffic and you'd also be
banned from engaging in deceptive or
misleading marketing practices to
distort the truth about your treatment
of Internet traffic in other words you
would have to tell the truth if this
California bill ultimately becomes the
law about what you're doing with
Internet traffic now the question is
will the stand and the answer is we
don't know because on the one hand as
passed by the FCC these types of state
and local laws mandating net neutrality
aren't actually allowed the other
and is that number one there are
numerous lawsuits against the FCC
challenging those provisions and number
two there's a possible legal argument
that rather than a bill like this being
net neutrality which would not be
allowed by the FCC provision saying no
state-level net neutrality if California
can argue these are business regulations
under the guise of consumer protection
arguably they'd be able to stand without
violating the federal net neutrality
repeal it's getting into legal questions
that are didn't have to be sorted out it
seems to me like a classic case of Tenth
Amendment versus Supremacy Clause in the
Constitution explain the Tenth Amendment
provides states rights anything not
granted by the federal government under
the Bill of Rights and thence premise
each Clause means that pretty much the
federal government Trump's the state
government and they have the final say
yeah this is a classic battle between
states rightists and those who are not
anti states rights but believe that the
federal government does govern all the
states I guess and it's going to be a
legal battle the good news is that
California and other states are at least
fighting back on something that's really
really important I mean this is a
paramount issue like campaign finance
net neutrality is an issue that impacts
almost any political issue that you care
about yeah a similar move was made in
Montana too right whereas Montana has
like 1 million people California is the
most populous state it has 40 million
people so I got to say this is more
significant that's why the California
thing could be so important because
California can be a sort of bellwether
for what could be possible in other
states there are other paths forward to
try to reinstate net neutrality type
regulations at the state level in
Wyoming is an example Wyoming did
something interesting where they passed
an executive order which narrowed who's
allowed to deliver services to the state
government so they're not regulating in
a way that conflicts with what the FCC
did they're simply saying by executive
order if you want to do business with
the state and you're an internet service
provider you have to do it with network
neutrality in place you can choose not
to do business with the state that's
your choice and that legally might be a
stronger path forward but the the big
picture is
different states are trying different
paths to put net neutrality back in and
I think that that is a really really
really important thing and we're going
to continue following